[Music]
hi I'm mark Kevin Chris Soria from
maniac pumpkin carvers and why I got in
touch with us to carbon up get into an
emperor palpatine
and they gave us this really cool new
knife that they want us to test out it's
always great to try out new tools and
see what kind of techniques that you can
get from different knives the texture of
his face is really going to work well
within the pumpkin grotesque kind of
faces are always really fun to carve
especially if there's a lot of age and
weathering and folds wrinkles are always
really fun for pumpkin carving this
knife is probably a jar jar binks but
for household vegetable chopping
[Music]